how's it going breasts my name is
pre-order bat this is a game based on
slender and it's made by Mark J Hadley
that's sanatorium I got this game
suggested to me I thought they meant
sanatorium which is a really old horror
style game and that game is just so old
I watched a let's play of it it's just
so old that it freaks the [ __ ] out of me
like the voice acting sounds like [ __ ]
and it make just makes you wanted
alright it's exactly like slender
apparently you collect notes ah that's
fun that is some nice and they'd uh look
at that blunt it took a spring I doesn't
whoa whoa brush I'm sorry I offended you
note I will take you more seriously now
in the future it's not very dark and I
have no idea how the monster would look
like that kind of bothers me a little
bit hey bench how you doing hey honey I
didn't know benches talk it's new
alright cut because jerez talking is not
that way up there we go nowhere to run
nowhere to run nowhere to hide I could
never sleep what are you doing there now
you look exactly like slender don't you
dare follow me bro sure shoot to go to
[ __ ] up it is slender I don't think it
would be slender stop following a bro
stop following me bro
[ __ ]
stop stop listen [ __ ] he's creepy as
hell
nicely doing that and now I'm going to
Ramsay I had it up his game is wrong
sorry yeah okay shut up all right yes
you are it's so bright tonight I love
you
out of sight not out of mind it sounds
like oh hell no oh hell no who flipped
you over alright I'm getting this
goosebumps and it starts itching when I
start sweating and I shot [ __ ] I hate it
all right don't worry best I hate this
feeling okay we're fine we're fine we're
fine breasts don't don't look at me like
that I can do it if we can do it as rest
that's it keep focusing alright alright
I think we're safe huh nothing thanks
alright how many notes do we have what
was that
while was that's what are you breathing
for it don't worry about it
don't even think about it okay this
looks pretty nice Oh dry rumblers wash
it clean hundred percent more suds I
don't even know what that is but I want
100 percent of it
[Music]
don't really like this okay I think
we're good breasts is this where I came
from
no it's not [ __ ] yeah no more no one
survives [ __ ] you I'll survive what's a
lion are the Lions now yep
such animal bad excuse of a lion
you call yourself with our thoughts we
created our world that is deep lion okay
shut up
have we have a number I don't like this
nobody gets that okay so frankly stander
knows how to moonwalk that's pretty cool
that was wondered how he wants that's
good I feel like I'm going insert I
don't so lost right now can't there be a
note here I refrigerator how ya doing
don't worry breasts Oh ice cream oh my
god ice cream oh my god it's like I'm
almost there [ __ ] me not you
shut up what are you doing here [ __ ]
hate em don't do anything all right you
can't follow me when I walk like that
there's something by the end of this
[Music]
okay we're good we're good we're good
did that just lit up I feel like I've
been here before
vagina I can't tell because [ __ ] give me
notes oh oh oh oh it's just me it's just
me it's just me it's just me that's dad
is me
stop complaining and I walk in circles
all right what no stop I hate when he
does that
I [ __ ] I walk in his circles that is not
no bueno no mana oh [ __ ] what am i doing
I feel drunk okay okay
no we're not good what that is [ __ ]
creepy okay we've been here stop shut up
I'm gonna get all the notes Prez don't
worry about it I'm a professional oh
this is new this is new I love it a
toilet
I can literally pee myself by playing
that's awesome no smoking [ __ ] all right
Oh note in it came from the fart oh hell
no
[Music]
what forest what [ __ ] forest I didn't
get the memo about a forest I hug the
wallpapers [ __ ] Amaka
oh dude shut up you look so stupid
I mean handsome don't kill me
continue [ __ ] no that was fun we got
to relive slender again alright cool
they're different there I read that
they're trying to make more maps and
stuff
it's definitely keeps me interesting for
me cuz I'm just so [ __ ] sick of
slender but this is fun this is fun we
should do it again sometime right
alright anyway I'm gonna hug my lab now
and hide in the darkness and I like and
favorite if you enjoyed the guy to come
abroad today and I'll see you in
[Music]
that is MIDI it all right back
looks like I have a mangina oh look a
dog is like oh my god is so awesome I
gotta stare at him
[ __ ] yeah my SEM like a man I'm a little
metal there I got that from licking no
don't say oh oh this is bright and nice
let's see what we got in the kitchen
lasagna baba what are you doing why did
he do that